ragazzi miei sono tornato con marco
quest'oggi perché siccome lui mi ha
introdotto al mondo di isaac che il
prodotto è la parola più giudizioso
borgo band mi ha lanciato nell'inferno
con questo gioco in mano togliamo allora
siccome il buon marco e molto coach
cielo è anche quando io gioco per i
cavoli miei io gli chiedo le cose oggi
lui mi farà visto che non c'è la coop
sulla switch facciamo che lui micov
vediamo se riesce a uccidere la madre
broglio nei tuoi non lo so vediamo
innanzitutto vorrei far notare quanto
trattasi di marco sia da nerd per chi
gioca isaac lo sa
tutte queste cose a sinistra non si
credo che ci siamo noi nel capitolo
camera che sfiga è qua sotto sotto di me
ci sono tutti questi cosi rossi che chi
ce li ha tutti probabilmente non è una
ragazza lui anche la ragazza quindi e in
solo meno del greco il quadro completo è
veramente bravo posso usare il mio
preferito almeno certo ai più forti
grazie però più facile perché per ora
non lo sanno
allora io qua non entrerei né cosa
perché ho tre vite fanno schifo io non
gioco da da un po e non mi ricordo più
l'uomo prende il cuore perché come si
lancia comico è veramente difficile sul
gioco non solo di spiegarvelo godetevi
il video e basta non rompendo da questo
film questo gioco parlavo prima compito
lorenzo intanto io veramente vi
consiglio di acquistare lo stesso rtp
che viaggiano molto spendere reti tra
parentesi
questo non è un play si no semplicemente
amore e allevare e amorali e tanti podio
per un placement perché come si fa a
fare un placement di un penso che tu
possa cosa sta roba qua strategies and
feel like i sky blues cuore dal fallo
uno spreco a ci sta e si riccardo fa
schifo ma si ricarica tempo però roba
d'altri ma ok figo parka vaccamorta park
faccio fiscale colpo è mai sai cosa che
tu hai dei neri però l'ha visto subito
la xc riusciti nei test rompere dalla
fir azioni come il problema è che tu hai
i mostri a livello più avanzato quindi
non sono neanche abituato dal giro che
fanno alcuni vai nel post prima di
questo quasi priva di uccidere loro e
poi si lui si spiega che lo sai che se
ti avvicini alloro loro sia lontano
non sapevo poco poco non mi fido di
stanza ad essere pronto questo è uno dei
boss più falso grazie se prende danno mi
incazzo io ho paura che mi faccia cosa
mettere bene anche un dato mai fra capi
up ci sia un bene mamma ea un attimo ma
secondo me c'è possibilità di decidere
quando e se sì del resto ragazzi alla
salute funziona così i cuori rossi poi
cura poi con articoli dossi quali dari
li perdi se tolgono vita però aprire per
dirlo fi darlo a tutta la stanza questa
è la è detto ci sono solo modo
no vuoi farti perdere testi colpi school
che si esplodano fanno cose per quando
parlo di questo tipo di ralph mothes
mondo guarda però funziona come una
bomba
cosa fare l'altro pure volevo primario è
meno ma da allora perché è vietato e
ricaricati
[Musica]
qualcuno spieghi questa è la puoi
scegliere cielo stato segreto ma qua si
è questo riferimento zelda 2 e io terrei
questo no sono solo ora super segreta
nulla è veramente soave torno torno
oppure può darti questa base
ma torniamo nuovo poi bombe joker un
gioco era di teletrasporto andiamo
sono chiave da dio non ho visto questo
cosa che fa lo usi e faust e dei raggi
bianchi dal cielo che ha distrutto tutto
però hai ancora più forte dei personaggi
diversi riuscirci lo stesso con questo
scopo tu parli come se stessi giocando
tutto ma devi venire bene ma pro in non
ho una vita quindi ho una famiglia e
vabbè andiamo addosso al detenuto che
mons vabbè dai processi
no
scoraggia intende
satana tu sei gli oggetti a me ei
ragazzi sono perugino no
dentro
caldo la testa di krampus
la prendo si è più forte di me fare bene
la lotta ai boss mi basta
ed io ho fatto schifo in una stanza mi
ha tolto tipo tra cuori prima se non
avessi fatto lo sai che se con la bbc la
bibbia allora in 14 chiave senza collo
non sta più nella rossa stomp yamaha
fortissimo quasi tutte le pietre ha dato
ci africo è il capo giusto e oltre di 20
0 la cucina che fini questa roma nel
leone
wow lo prendo questo studio igienico che
c'è la possibilità dopo che lo aprì che
si richiuda in poi vedo di voci altro
già moltissimo grazie all
[Musica]
la mia a prato per me
giorno
cavalca che male però
vai o rapallo e non so chi sia grazie
però si dice
vasto visto blocco fare qualcosa pure
avvolto distanza ed ho capito ma non è
quello il danno il mio problema è la
gente che mi ammazza poi ucciderla
privato questa d'angelo ma come su due
ragazzi prima dicevo allora perché non
ci posso credere
però pensavo di morire pensavo veramente
io sono morto in vari circoli design fa
pensavo veramente detto sono morto così
[Risate]
ok quello di portarlo di nuovo grazie ai
tantissimi fiati madryn terribile
principe di fare il nostro
solo così questo libro di questo due
continuano a devastare all'inizio gli
spaventi pure delle cagate poi
migliorativa
lo vivono
meglio
i cugini sugli ordini
mamma mamma mamma mamma sai c'è un
battuto
non vorrei ora che sei stato
di spalla le monete spaura una cosa a
caso ogni volta usate sardo è abbastanza
grande
vajassa wow
no l'ho vista dopo cristian l'ho vista
dopo porca vacca
da tali che muove bene tra di loro
pensano che innova falsi esatta della
madre che mi prenderò ne avrebbe visto
mappa via brocchi mi sono veramente mio
blog di eventi pausa di volta per
lavezzi dopo attraverso stanze non
sembra niente ai misteri
si lavora post terremoto schifo
questo è quello che che evoca le lame
porti snow fai male proprio male anche
quelli là dell'ostacolo allora ho deciso
ha detto aspetta che ora fanno non solo
va cambiato addosso ai veramente urlato
fortissimo vi sono
pelvi lo scudo guardare alla crisi
interiore in faccia
allora questo è il paradiso tu questo
libro va beh cari amici questo era il
primo episodio di the binding of isaac
con marco siccome io movimenti di fare
un episodio solo però siccome sta
durando tanto e mi è mancata la voce che
è una figura veramente barbina se questa
dorando tanto abbiamo diviso in due
episodi perché nel presepio cerchiamo di
arrivare a satana
scusatemi mi chiedo scusa a tutti quelli
che giocano pro ad isaac io no no no
invece quelli che non ci giocano
probabilità non capito la metà delle
cose forse neanche per la divertente da
guardare se come va bene ci viene un
prossimo video ragazzi ringrazio marco
brave partecipato se non si rischia tv
al canale e noi ci vediamo come al
solito
[Musica]